the modern world
firmly equates the intelligent person
with the well-read person reading books
a lot of books has become the hallmark
of brilliance
as well apparently as the supreme
gateway to understanding
if we don't read four of this year's
major prize-winning books as well as
maybe
seven fascinating titles that have
received ardent reviews in the sunday
supplements since march
then will be condemned to guilt and
shame
yet amidst this pressure to eat our way
through an ever larger number of titles
we might pause to reflect on a
fascinating aspect
of the pre-modern world this world
never put people under any pressure to
read very much at all
reading was held to be extremely
important but the number of
new books one read was entirely by the
by
this wasn't principally an economic
point books were very expensive of
course
but this wasn't really the issue what
mattered was to read a few books
very well not squander one's attention
promiscuously
on a great number of volumes the
pre-modern world directed us to read so
little
because it was obsessed by a question
that modernity likes to dodge
what is the point of reading and
it had answers to take a supreme example
christians and muslims located the value
of reading in a very specific and narrow
goal
the attainment of holiness to read was
to try to approximate the mind of god
in each case this meant that one book
and one book only
the bible or the quran was held up as
vastly and incomparably more important
than any other
to read this book repeatedly and with
great attention
probably five or so pages every day was
thought more crucial
than to rush through a whole library
every week
in fact reading widely would have been
regarded with suspicion because
most other books would to some extent
have to prove
misleading and distracting similarly in
the ancient greek world
one was meant to focus in on a close
knowledge of just two books
homer's odyssey and his iliad because
these were deemed the perfect repository
of the greek code of honor
and the best guides to action in
military and civilian affairs
we can pick up some of this minimalist
attitude to reading
in early visual depictions of one of the
heroes of christian scholarship
saint jerome who was by all accounts the
supreme
intellect of christendom a man who
translated the greek and hebrew portions
of the bible into latin
wrote a large number of commentaries on
scripture and is now the patron saint of
libraries and librarians
but despite all this scholarly effort
when it came to showing where
and how saint jerome worked one detail
stands out
there are almost no books in his famous
study
strikingly the most intelligent and
thoughtful intellectual
of the early church seems to have read
fewer things
than an average modern eight-year-old
the modern world has dramatically parted
ways
with this minimalist ancient approach to
reading
we have adopted an enlightenment mantra
that runs in a very different direction
stating that there should be no limit to
how much we read because
in answer to the question of why we do
so
there is only one response that will
ever be encompassing
or ambitious enough we read in order
to know everything but we can hazard an
observation
this exhaustive approach to reading does
not make us particularly happy
so in order to ease and simplify our
lives
we might dare to ask a very
old-fashioned question
what am i reading for and this time
rather than answering in order to know
everything we might parcel off a much
more limited focused and useful goal
we might for example decide on a new
mantra
to guide our reading henceforth we might
want to read
in order to learn to be content
nothing less and nothing more with this
new
far more targeted ambition in mind much
of the pressure to read constantly and
randomly starts to fade
once we know that we're reading to be
content we don't need to chase
every book published this season we can
zero in on titles that best explain
what we deem to be the constituent parts
of contentment
so for example we may need a few key
books that will explain our psyches to
us
that will teach us about how families
work and how they might work better
that can take us through how to find a
job we can love or how to develop the
courage to develop our opportunities
we'll probably need some books that talk
about friendship and love
sexuality and health some books that
gently guide us to how to minimize
regret
and learn to die well the more we
understand what reading
is for us the more we can enjoy intimate
relationships
with a few works only the truly
well-read person
isn't the one who has read a gargantuan
number of books
it's someone who has let themselves be
deeply shaped
by just a few very well chosen titles
self-knowledge is a new essay book that
takes us on a journey
into our deepest most elusive selves
and arms us with a set of tools to
understand our characters properly
you